to make sure that the security is really
a matter
of priority so you're also asking them
for more equipment and
and resources for the army for the armed
forces
absolutely because it's a young army uh
is still an
amber you know universities but over
they are well trained
they are trained by mexico they are
trained by ecuador
uh so so i believe they have received a
good
uh great training they can do the jobs
particularly protect the border but
unfortunately
we've been facing a lot of resistance uh
to help the armed forces out and protect
the body
and most of the time even to our company
the national police
because in every country even here in
the united states whenever there was a
very real situation
the national the police then they called
the national guard
but uh we don't understand why they
refused us to have it
we need to have an armed forces because
our country was created by military
so it is very important to have that and
so
our borders can be protected and to have
a better control over the bodies
because it is is it not unacceptable
to have the commanders the foreign
commanders to entire country
to kill a president and to live without
any concern
i don't think i don't think any
international partners
should be part of this
thanks uh tracy unless you have a
follow-up let's go to jenny hansler with
cnn
hi ambassador thank you so much for
doing this can you hear me yes i can
thank you i was wondering if you could
get into a little more specifics about
who in the us government you're in touch
with
um is it mostly the state department the
white house are you seeking
fbi assistance for example um how long
do you expect the airport to be
shuttered
and then separately do you have any more
i know the investigation is ongoing but
you have details on how
exactly these attackers were able to
access the residence
uh to commit this crime i don't have uh
that's too much details yet uh but i can
tell you
uh you know uh they have some
information
with regards to uh those commandos
because we have video footages showing
that it's a good
well professional killers uh they are
speaking in spanish
uh uh they carried out that attack
and then when it comes to the who i had
conversation i've been in touch with the
white house
uh uh and then the state department
i've been talking to my colleague the us
ambassador uh
but um but so far we we just don't want
to go ahead of the investigation we just
want to
to let the process unfolded
so we can get more details later on
and how long do you expect the airport
to stay closed
uh we believe once we we have the
situation under control
uh you know because it's very early
uh this is this horrible act was
committed this morning
uh we just mean uh known
uh we think we needed that time to make
sure that the situation
is under control to make sure that uh
our activities can resume safely and
then we will consider that
thanks uh could we go to courtney
mcbride with the wall street journal
thank you mr ambassador uh you mentioned
a couple of times resistance to
strengthening the armed forces
and using them to secure the country i
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit more about what the nature of that
resistance is
and then additionally i'm sorry was
there was there
an advance uh warning of a threat
specific threat to the president
thank you i i believe the president
himself
mentioned that in an interview he gave
to
to a spanish newspaper and
in january he mentioned about uh
he believed a lot of people want to kill
him want to get him killed because of
his policies
although the reforms is carrying out
but we didn't have any warning when it
comes to that thing today
uh when i when i spoke about the western
because there are many people
uh and then part of our international
partners
they always are reservation on the armed
forces
because they want to you know to link
the former armed forces what we had that
was dismantled in 94
to the new armed forces which is
completely different because this
current emphasis
was made through recommendations of the
anti-american defense board
here in washington part of the oas
that was a process that was carried out
by the anti-american body in two years
and to make the recommendations of what
we call the white book
on how to re-establish the army and we
followed exactly
what the accommodation said this there
is nothing illegal here
and therefore we still despite of this
we still have resistance our reservation
from international partners
saying that this is the armed forces are
priority the
the national policy is the only one
going to end the constitution
most of the time they pretend defending
or they're accusing us of violating but
that same constitution say there are two
forces in the country the armed forces
and the national police but they say
that that was
they want to strengthen the national
police let's ignore the army there is no
place for the army
but at the same time when you're looking
at the strengthening of the national
police
you don't you don't see really enough
you don't see anything
so i think we need to stop with that
hypocrisy
let us have to have let us have the army
because
a lot of islands in the caribbean they
have their own armed forces
the dominican republic next to us they
we don't see why we cannot have an armed
forces just to protect the border
because we have a post border drug
dealers
trafficking human trafficking
uh you know uh international terrorism
all those things
but the the most important question i
would ask this morning
how in the world a commenders
mercenaries well professional well
uh or trained could enter the country
without knowing
and committed that such horrible act and
left
because we know probably most of them
have left or probably they are still
inside the country
but there is no plane the airport is not
open where are they
probably they use the border to cross
and left so
would you imagine if we had enough if we
had an arm force that was controlling
the border
it would have been difficult
thank you could uh can we go to simon
lewis with reuters
i can hear me yes i can hear you
hi thank you hi thank you ambassador um
i just wanted to clarify a couple of
things regarding the
um the specifics of of
of the assassination um you mentioned
this video footage i just want to
clarify that's the same footage that's
sort of been seen publicly um and it's
shot from a from a neighbor's house is
that
is that the the only footage that um you
know and is that
is that footage sort of in the
government's uh possession
at this time i i don't know yet uh
if it's anyone uh but i know that's uh
many of them have been securing on their
social networks and i believe uh the
national police have also interested
them
and probably they have also footages
from all the points
but uh they are still part of the
investigation that's what i said i don't
want to go ahead of the investigation
i will let them to care about their jobs
and then after that we'll know some
details
but you uh consider these the video
footage
that we've seen to be credible and
you're sort of basing
your assessment that you say these are
mercenaries and commandos
that's based on on the video that we've
seen
yeah it seems to me that's what i get
from experts and polo pens
uh the way it was the way they saw them
uh they were speaking spanish and they
presented themselves
as dea agents and uh
as we know this is not the way the
pirates
and haiti whenever there is an operation
it's well played with the u.s embassy
the
haitian police
i believe they are fake these agents and
they're speaking spanish
and it is a well orchestrated attack and
those are professionals
they the expert also the video at the
semester listen to the conclusion that
those are work carried out those are
professional killers
thank you unless somebody else has
another question uh
can we go back to yamiche here's a
follow-up
thank you again ambassador for taking a
couple more questions
um the first you talked about the the
the current prime minister being the
person who is in charge now
do you anticipate the new prime minister
being inaugurated or
what do you think that that will be um
delayed until
further notice or indefinitely i believe
this is something that has
to work to be worked out between the
foreign i cannot tell you exactly what
would be the procedure
but what i can tell you since there is a
vacuum
we the interim prime minister and the
government
they have to step in to make sure that
uh
there is uh someone at the helm of the
country for the moment
uh now when it comes to the the prime
minister that was named order decision
that would be left to the national
authorities and
and they will relay to me afterwards
but for now that's the only thing i can
tell you and then
you made it pretty clear it sounds like
that you think that these
assassins came through the the border
with the dominican republic is that
clear
that what you're insinuating and do you
think that the people in the jamaican
republic may be responsible for this
no we'll never say that what i said i
didn't know
how they came into the country but what
i said
probably after carrying out that such
horrible act
the airport is closed this morning there
was no airplane
therefore if in case they would have
left the country there is no only one
way to leave the country with the
borders and that's why i made my case
i said if the border was well protected
by the armed forces
it would have been difficult because uh
the national police doesn't have that
mission to protect borders
so that's why i understand that
uh this is something we need to look at
uh
how they left you know because we don't
know how they came in
but for sure if in case they left
already their country we have to ask
ourselves
how did how did they do that there is
only one way to live
so you don't think it could be a private
plane you think it would have to be on
land through
the border uh i don't know by the plane
i believe that our tower control
our of now the system civil radiation
system would have
detected them they would have seen them
uh i don't think it would be easy like
this
but as i said before since the
investigation is still going on
let's wait on to to see what the
authorities will tell us
what do they what they they discover as
details
and really quickly i know you said that
you know hey presidents have been
assassinated in other countries i just
wonder maybe
do you have any message for people who
are just terrified living in haiti right
now sheltering in place
what would you say to them i believe as
every
asian nationals living in haiti probably
they woke up this morning shock
because uh and their lifetime they never
heard of that we
as i told you before we had that in our
history
that was that's that's that's the reason
that led to the usn
occupation and election 1915. uh
we had we studied it in history but
the fact today we are living it is
something different
uh that's why i told you that i guess
those people
they are shocked to hear something like
this
but that's why we calling we i believe
in it the court authorities
will do our best to assure
the people that they are doing
everything possible to restore order and
to make sure that
the people can continue to carry out the
duty of their life
uh but even though in a very difficult
situation circumstances
but it is very uh you know imperative
for the government to send that signal
to the haitian people
and a signal of calmness of uh
you know even though it's a very
difficult time
but the signal of unity
and car and to restore order
and to make sure that we continue
as a nation to move forward together
thank you mr investor if you have time
for a few more questions um
let's go to joel gurkey with the
washington examiner
all right thank you ambassador for doing
this uh and uh
my condolences again for this this
tragedy
um i wanted to follow up on something
you said at the beginning you mentioned
that this
uh this attack is a threat to the region
um could you elaborate on the nature of
of how this is a threat to the region
what what do you worry might unfold and
do you think there's any
foreign involvement or something in this
okay the reason i said that because
uh to have an elected uh
democratic elected president in office
has been assassinated
it's not only a threat to haiti to our
democracy
this is something that should not happen
that's why it's very important to have
the international condemnation for that
and this afternoon at 2 30 we have a
security department
a council os meeting to
to discuss this issuance because it is a
matter of regional issues security issue
because that's why we as a nation and
the region and the americas
we are not alone we are part of a
community
so that's why it's very important to say
that it is a threat to the region
is it referred to anti-american
democratic charter
you know so to to that's the political
discussion we cannot
have uh uh political discussions
or disputes to come to that to killing
of president and function
that's why we believe our differences
should be dealt with
uh peaceful negotiation and means
therefore we have to reject and we have
to condemn
and that's why i said it's a threat to
our age it is effective our region
because when democracy is threatened and
the country of the region
is different to others
thank you uh mr pastor uh cindy sane
with uh with voice of america
yes thank you so much uh mr ambassador
you mentioned the possibility of this um
armed commando going over
to the dominican republic are
authorities there cooperating with you
in this manhunt
uh i i should uh speak to the
to the authorities and parapens i
believe the national police
i'm sure most of the time whenever there
is such a frame
uh that i always believe there is a
collaboration from media
or militaries and authorities uh
there are there i have no doubt that
they will assist
and this because as i said before
those folks those criminals after
committing
such an act if they are not in the
country right now
there is only one way for them to leave
their countries this through their
borders
because there is no plane even though
they would have their own private plane
somewhere else the system the civil
aviation will have detected them
so that's why we call on the
international
community to assist us to
to join forces together to investigate
and see how we can identify those
killers
and for them to be brought to justice
because
the killer president today uh
if we allow that to continue tomorrow
they may feel free to go somewhere else
and kill another president
because we don't know those those forces
they have to have a response
and the response will be a coordinated
response from all over the world from
all
particularly from our region it's very
important to do that
thanks uh let's go back to kerry with
npr
i thank you um i just wanted to know if
you could be more specific about
what your plans are for security and
when
would you ask the us for direct
intervention
is that something you're thinking about
is there a level of
insecurity that would get that would you
allow the marines
to come into haiti given the
historical situation with the marines in
haiti
yeah it is not a decision for me to make
uh
i think uh what we do we
present the situation to them uh the
security assessment
the experts will have to make them and
then so they will decide
on the unfolding of the situation
uh because as i told you this is
something that happened this morning
it's almost 1 p.m we still don't know
how it's going to be unfolded
we need to wait but the experts will
have to be will be able to make an
assessment
and see what kind of assistance they can
give
but uh now it's not to me to call or to
request
any marriage or whatsoever so uh
it's uh it's between authorities
the u.s and foreigners and the haitian
authorities to discuss
and to assess the situation and see
where they want to help how they can
help
uh carrie unless you have a follow-up
let's go to uh
let's get to jenny from cnn ambassador
thanks i just have two quick
follow-ups um can you go into specifics
on how you know that these assailants
have in fact
left the country and when can we expect
the first lady to be moved to miami is
that an imminent
move this is what i told you i i told
you that if in case
they are still in the country but we
don't know but if in case they are no
longer into the country
there is only one way for them to go out
is the border that's what i said
so therefore it's very important i
believe that the dominican republic
authorities
will be more than available to assist
and under under under search for the
investigation
uh but we we do i did say
it's very important to consider that we
don't know
how they came in but we know for sure
if they are not currently in haiti we
know for sure there was only one way for
them to leash
is the border there was no other way so
uh
uh when it comes to the first lady i
believe the arguments are being made
i i should double check very soon if she
has not left yet
but uh i can tell you that uh necessary
arguments
have been medicine this morning to month
to miami hospital
well thank you uh if nobody else has any
questions i think uh you've been very
generous with your time particularly
under these circumstances
thank you very much for taking the time
to speak with us it's deeply appreciated
thank you so very much for having me and
my message would be uh to my fellow
citizens
with this lamentable situation kill our
presidents
even though someone you may didn't we
may like him or not the most important
thing
he was the president of haiti but now
let
us use that situation to see
how we can you know come together
and see how we can move together forward
sure thank you mr ambassador if you if
you have time for just one quick one uh
just one more person that came to the
queue uh karen de young from the
washington post
thank you i'm sorry i just quickly um
is it not possible that the assailants
could have left by sea
you said a number of times that the only
possible way for them to leave
is across the land border yeah
that's the possibility as well but
that's this is what i'm telling you that
we don't want to go ahead of the
investigation
we need to find out in case they came in
or they came in
uh for instance let us consider they
came by sea
but they have to have necessary means
cars to transport them to their
president residents
therefore the investigation will have to
look into it who help them
so this that's going to be a long
investigation that's why i don't want to
go ahead of them the situations
but now we are considering so many uh uh
uh
issues so many aspects of this but it's
possible they came in by
making my company they might come back
we don't know how long they've been in
haiti we don't know but the
investigation
will determine all those things just
quickly um did the president not have
guards around his residence and
if so what happened to them of course
this is also part of the investigation
uh they are being investigated they are
being questioned to find out what
happened
uh but that's the only thing i can tell
you now
uh so once uh we have more details we'll
share them with you
so there was no exchange of fire with
the cards or
no guards were wounded in this uh we
i don't have that information yet i will
double check and to make sure that if
there was any
uh casualties on the can on the side of
the
other guards and finally you said the
attackers were foreigners do you
have any sense of where they might have
been from i mean
we don't know yet we don't know yet but
uh what i can tell you there are
foreigners they are speaking spanish
between themselves because
those are footages or videos we have we
strongly believe they might come from
outside
already
thank you
well thank you mr ambassador uh i know
you have a hard stop shortly um but
thank you again thank you very much for
taking the time
thank you very much thank you so much
for having me it's been a pleasure to be
with you
thank you jenny as well thank you sean
and uh your colleagues appreciate it
um i'll be sending you the link shawn's
to pass on to your colleagues
but as the afternoon wears on if any of
you are looking to
do an obituary and you're looking for
information about
the um the late president please don't
hesitate to reach out
um or if you're looking for a like a
fact sheet please don't hesitate to
reach out
sean has my information um and i can put
my email in the chat
as we start to to wrap things up but of
course
again i want to thank everyone for um
for your interest
and um and your time thank you so much
mr ambassador
thank you bye-bye thank you
thanks sean thank you all right
everybody bye now
you